hey rich how are you how's it going man
it's it's been an emotionally raw
stretch but uh yeah you know i i
wouldn't want people think wrongly of me
when i say i go to bed with you uh often
uh
i promise not to say that publicly
although this is being recorded now so
that could be held against me
but i just finished uh just finished
your talk with a guy i've loved uh
uh even though he back then he was a
think tank on the other side of the
aisle but i've always loved uh
uh arthur brooks he's just such a brooks
yeah that was a great conversation yeah
thank you i mean i'm so i'm touched and
honored that uh you make the time to
listen to the show i can't believe
that's possible but you know arthur
makes my job easy he's such a you know a
beautiful
font of wisdom and it is interesting as
you know him being somebody who was head
of a conservative think tank um my sense
is that he he really doesn't want to
talk about politics that's not his
interest level right now i mean you
covered it well which you know all of us
being in our 50s
he definitely
has made a shift away from this
crazy think tank world but he was moving
that way he wrote this amazing book
about love um which i think was one
before this one
that i i
my stack of books right now is just
trying to figure out how do we talk to
each other in a country that's spiraling
uh in in kind of a into a culture of
contempt
um
and he's thought been really thoughtful
about that and i think highly influenced
by the dalai lama
yeah i think that's i think that's
accurate and uh you know i think that's
a a good place to just jump right into
it i mean i know your time is tight and
i really appreciate you guys
they said 15 minutes
i i've been looking to talk to rich roll
for like since i started listening to
his podcast i fell in love with your
podcast it was one of your best of years
you know like at the end of the year you
do the you sample from all the ones
so i i've been looking to to have a
conversation with you for a very long
time so i told myself to give me at
least an extra 15 minutes because i knew
i was going to fanboy all over you for
the first uh first 15 we wouldn't get to
the subject matter well you got me all
buttered up and i'm going to hold you to
that because i'm definitely you know
somebody who wants to get you in the
studio and we'll do the full kit and
caboodle podcast at at some point when
you're your journey it's your journey i
read founding finding ultra and
uh i think that you can see in my
opinion the universe sort of using you i
think that not only athletics but also
your struggles with with addiction have
made your power of empathy and your
ability to connect you know i always say
that broken people
uh we're all broken more than we maybe
want to admit but you you not only does
it let good stuff in but it also creates
more points of contact which you can
connect with other broken people and
i think that uh you have this wonderful
ability to
uh connect with the people you interview
that in a real way in a substantive way
to go a little deeper than some some of
the
general interviews we often see i think
it's a gift
i appreciate that it's uh it's it's an
honor to be able to do it and it's
certainly nourishing for me and uh to be
able to kind of give it back to the
audience is just you know something that
just gives my life purpose and meaning
um so i'm very grateful to be on this
journey and to be talking to you today
my friend
thank you let's get into it yeah please
go ahead
um
you know obviously uh
obviously um
you know the country is under a lot of
strain right now we're we're uh you know
enduring um some challenges not the
least of which is
all of the mass shootings uh what
transpired in uvalde and subsequent
incidents that we've all uh born witness
to these tragic events
and so i really wanted to kind of focus
the limited time that that we have with
you today on the subject of gun violence
and and gun control and i thought it
might be
beneficial to just hear your perspective
like what is your bird's eye view on
kind of where we're at as a nation how
are you thinking about this issue right
now and and perhaps like some thoughts
on why this is so
intractable in terms of finding
solutions so i'm a kid that grew up in
the suburbs and uh new jersey and
not part of a hunting culture and my
granddad to take me out once but you
know it's a suburban town outside of of
new york and gun violence didn't affect
my life
but i've lived the last um
got since the late 90s in new york new
jersey in the central ward and
um gun violence immediately impacted my
life on my first nights sleeping
in in an apartment i got across the
street from the projects i eventually
moved into them
i started hearing gunshots and at night
i still remember coming out one day and
there being a
sort of tail end of a shooting and since
then i've lost uh young kids i've known
uh to gun violence and and seen the
horrific everyday realities of gun
violence in america and it's often the
violence we don't talk about it's
stunning to me how
we as a nation
doesn't even pop into our consciousness
unless we have these horrific mass
shootings but every single day
uh
on average more than 300 americans are
shot over 100 americans die
and the violence is everything from
domestic violence which we don't talk
about
to suicides which we don't talk about
enough
um and now we have this stunning rise of
of hate in our country where since 9 11
we've lost more americans due to
americans killing americans right-wing
groups from synagogues to churches
to supermarkets
um
and then and then obviously uh school
shootings like we just had so i it's a
very personal issue for me uh
i i i
you know i i'm some of my own personal
trauma
uh being in and around
shootings and and so i came here
um as the only united states senator
that lives in a low-income black and
brown uh
neighborhood who's had shootings on
their block most recently in 2018 a
young man shahadu i i used to live in
the same building with
the police
officer who was giving me the account
said it was like his head blew up it was
an assault rifle that he got
and so it's been frustrating to me that
um
to live in a country where
uh you know
since the time that you and i've been
alive as guys in their 50s we've had
more people die to gun violence than in
every single war in america combined
yeah and so when you start asking me why
something hasn't changed
um i think it's too easy and convenient
to say
it's just washington
because we've seen
change happen against impossible odds
before when four little girls died in
the bombing in birmingham
you you saw a nation mobilize
to demand change and so i remind people
all the time
about this place
you know there's an old trope saying
here that they say often that change
doesn't come from washington it comes to
washington you know it wasn't a bunch of
guys on the senate floor in the
in the 1920s that said hey fellas
let's give these women a right to vote
it happened because people demanded it
uh as frederick douglass says if there's
no struggle there's no progress power
concedes nothing without a demand
and so we have tolerated for a very long
time in this country a level of carnage
and violence and death
that we've almost normalized because
days and days go by without us
doing enough and so
i can give you stuff that you know and i
i've heard listen to you
uh you enough of your podcast and i've
heard you express
understandable skepticism if not
cynicism about washington and politics
there are very powerful lobbies there's
money
there's um
uh
you know people's ambition
you know is a real consequence to
congress people running in red districts
where
districts have been drawn
where they're always worried about being
primaried by somebody on their right i
was on meet the press recently with a
guy who just lost a senate race who
lowered violence in his north carolina
city 50 but he was running against
somebody that had a gun in their belt
he said for most of their commercials
and he lost in a primary because the guy
casted him soft on guns
but i i don't think that i think that's
a convenient and easy excuse just to
blame it on washington it's almost like
surrendering responsibility and not
understanding that we all have a role to
change this nightmare and it's more than
just those
real things that i just i just mentioned
yeah i think uh
you know that that makes me
you know want to know more about and my
colleague adam skolnick is is on the
line too and i know he wants to chime in
on this
the the kind of lived experience of you
being a legislator a senator and and and
what that experience is like that
perhaps we're not aware of like if there
is to the extent that there's
frustration like why can't we just get a
law passed or what is actually going on
like when you
uh as somebody who cares deeply about
this issue and and is working so
diligently to
change the law and and and move our
country forward in a new direction on
this
on this subject matter like what are the
obstacles that you encounter on a daily
basis or or what do we as the public
you know not see about
what that is like for you so
look i've seen the best of this place
and i've seen the worst of it you know
where we've been able to hammer out
really great
bills you know our criminal justice
system is an outrage we're a nation that
takes our addicted our mentally ill
or poor or black and brown we stiff
stuck stick them in jails when they
often need help
or health care or counseling or trauma
and treatment
and we put them in our jails and you
know we've passed some good bills to try
to start changing
this nation from being a the country
where we still are with one out of every
three incarcerated women on the planet
earth are in the united states
and so we've passed some bills that have
liberated thousands of people that
that's the best of us
um we have a long way to go though and
i've seen the worst of us you know we
just passed an anti-lynching bill
um more than a century after it was
first introduced
when thousands of blacks were being
killed and we couldn't even make
lynching a federal crime until
and so i i
i
i
you know i've seen the um the corporate
gun lobby and how powerful they are
i've seen them change i think after
columbine
wayne lapierre said you know we need to
make universal background checks he was
for a lot of things
but the culture has slipped on on the
sort of
uh
within the nra world where they are
resisting and fighting any change
whatsoever and they are a very powerful
lobby
for people who are concerned about um
real re-election
um
[Music]
and so like right now we're we're we're
i've watched now i've been here eight
nine years
and i have seen those americans who are
really willing to
do something different dig in organize
put show more pressure on politics
changed laws on states you know since
parkland there's been a whole lot of
state laws that have changed for the
better
um
but here um it's been more difficult i
think we're actually going to get
something done you know i was talking
with uh
senator murphy and a group of house
members
that there's a there's hope here that
something can get done but i'm i'm going
to be candid it's going to be very
incremental
necessary things but nowhere near
sufficient to end the kind of carnage
what we're seeing on a regular basis
yeah
um senator booker is you're talking
about the election cycle and and the
pressure
to get reelected um how you know when we
see these stats of the nra and how much
they're contributing to people like
mitt romney or
you know mitch mcconnell people who you
could argue are bigger than the nra in
some ways they have their own kind of
brand but they're still under the sway
of an organization like that does that
speak to how hard it is to raise money
and compete in politics like what is the
draw there or like is it more that
they're afraid of the primary like what
what do you think is the draw for some
of these bigger names that could you
think you would be able to win without
them so again you're getting into the
psychology of of your colleagues is
often a
[Music]
a dangerous odyssey you can lose your
own mind trying to figure out people's
different motivations
um
the nra is not the biggest donor down
here and and and money i mean it's
really one of the toxins of our of our
of of of our government i think uh when
citizens united passed and corporations
now can pour tons and tons of money
strengthens the corporate gun lobby
because remember these are
corporations who are having a field day
they're selling guns in our country
you know at a level that we could have
never imagined every man woman and child
in america from babies to 99 year olds
could have one gun and then we'd still
have 70 million more guns out in our
streets
um but i don't know if it's just the
money they're contributing
and and you know again i like for
example i gave up all corporate money it
was fourth center to do so i just didn't
want to give anybody
reason to question my motives um but i
know that there as you said there are
people that can raise money if they
didn't get the whatever 30 000 from the
corporate gun lobby but they they i
think their power a lot of it lies in
their ability to mobilize people and get
them out to vote
singularly on this issue
and that's pretty powerful if you know
you're in a
election where
if it if you don't have that a rating
and you're going to be you're going to
be beat up by it by somebody else who's
who really has whipped up this idea
that um that that this person is going
to be a part of the um group in
washington is going to try to take away
your guns
you know when gun sales spike when
democrats get elected because they have
again and you can listen to the to the
rhetoric because they're told people are
told
that you're going to lose your people
who believe a very narrow version
believe that they're going to lose your
gun rights so that's a that's a base not
in my world but that's a base i think
for
uh that people are concerned about in
primaries
yeah what's interesting is that
that being said it does seem like the
nra is out of step with its constituency
because the polling demonstrates
clearly that most people are in favor of
rational gun control and yet the nra
still wields so much power
to you know rebut
the public sentiment on this issue and
so i guess i'm curious about you
mentioned
senator murphy chris murphy from
connecticut he's put together this
bipartisan
consortium of legislators to really work
on rational gun control like are you
like sanguine about the possibilities
here because that does seem like a
something that's new and different from
what we've seen in the past yeah i just
want to dwell on that point you made
first which is such an important point
and i should have mentioned it already
this is not a partisan issue
it really is not
and the problem often
with our country is we we try to reduce
things into the binary world as demo
republican
when i've i've listened to your show
enough to know that you realize that's
not the case i mean the the stranglehold
that big ag has down here is not a
partisan issue
chemicals that are being sprayed on our
foods that are in our bloodstream breast
milk and the like it's not a partisan
issue tech issues are not partisan
issues and and we as americans have so
much more in common the lines
uh the dividers are nowhere near as
strong as the ties that bind us but but
this this uh
political industrial complex
uh that will try to parse us along these
tribes uh i think that's and make us
believe that we're different that's a
problem there's a whole raft of common
sense gun safety
things that
i've seen comedians go to nra
conventions and ask people about
universal background checks and you just
see these nra members saying all this
about i'm worried about my guns being
taken oh but
but you know
universal background checks heck yeah we
need to have them to stop criminals from
getting guns so this is not a partisan
issue amongst americans it's a partisan
issue down here
and um and that's a lot of the
disconnect um folks have got to
um
on the republican side democratic side
whatever you identify begin to make this
a a central issue in your political
behavior as far as me being optimistic
i'm look i'm a prisoner of hope but i
always
differentiate hope from optimism hope
stares the wretched truth
of the world in the face doesn't deny it
but but still believes ultimately that
something can be done and so i've seen
this come around and i can't if i lost
hope that we could do something i don't
think i could continue doing this job i
will tell you again
that washington watchers
do think that there are the makings
right now because of you know chris
murphy said this to me today said this
to a group of us today
that his sense was that
a lot of folks went home
and and heard from people within their
that identify as their tribe the
republicans
and and were so dismayed about this
because at the end of the day
we are all hugging our children if you
have them before they go to school
there's a lot of that worry i think that
they're feeling which is opening the
door to do a little bit but i do not
have
a belief
um that in this bill we're going to see
the kind of comprehensive things
that most americans republican democrat
independent would want to see but we got
to start just like trevor noah's uh
monologue the other day like we have to
start somewhere and we got to iterate
on that and just uh just to get anything
and
i love history
people look at the civil rights movement
so it was in the 60s people started in
the in
you know
uh uh you know a philip randolph and
others were working on a march on
washington far before the one we know
about uh in the 60s they were doing
activism and protests and working and
making small changes uh thurgood
marshall was out there changing laws and
and more so i agree with you the this
first of all we have started the
parkland kids the moms demand action
gabby giffords organization there
there's a chapter in every single state
um of mom's demand action for example
that are making a difference in local
elections city county state elections so
this is a movement the question is is
are you a part of it or not because i
think what martin luther king said at
very frustrating points
in the in the civil rights movement
remember his letters from the birmingham
jail were not to the
racists
he was talking to good people and what
he said is what we have to repent in
this day and age and these words echo in
this moment what we have to repent for
is not simply the vitriolic words and
violent actions of the bad people but
the appalling silence and inaction of
the good people and so that's the
question is to me it's very binary i
don't i don't don't tell me what your
beliefs are uh show me who you are
through your actions are you part of the
movement to change these laws are you
doing more than you did before uvaldi
are you doing more than you did before
buffalo or you're doing the same things
you were doing before those two mass
shootings and expecting other people to
make the change that you want to see in
your country yeah you spoke about um
this kind of increased contempt um
in terms of the volume i guess
that's speaking to polarization but also
speaking to kind of
i guess information silos and how that
can turn up the the volume and the heat
on some uh
issues like this one
um it seems like a tragedy like this
the break the breaking of all of us or
like if the united states is our common
body and we're we're broken it seems
like that should be the place to latch
on and to do some good right i mean
that's what we were talking about but
maybe before
uh we started to record this this
interview uh how how
a time of brokenness can be a time can
be the perfect time to come together are
you seeing anything like that uh i know
that you're kind of
trying to
to make us not expect too much from this
coming law but are you are you seeing
any of that are you hearing any of that
in the hallways
a little bit more coming together at all
so i do think that they're hurt
and and
shattered more than broken how much we a
lot of us have been
is creating a climate for change and and
the rhythms
of washington dc are often in those
moments where
of where we share a common pain
sometimes we can find common purpose and
that's again one of the reasons why i
think we're going to get something
incremental done or at least i'm hoping
and praying that we will um
but i i have to be candid with you we
had a hearing today
all about uh replacement theory and for
those who don't know what that is
it's been it's been around for
generations it was around about the
catholics and the southern europeans
that were coming here to replace
protestant americans um
it's this idea that there is a
quote-unquote true american i'm a black
guy who can who skip gates trace my
history back to the 1640s but um in this
country but
there's this idea uh that that uh
and you hear it you remember that
they're marching with tiki torches in
virginia jews will not replace us so
the the the hearing the professors that
were there and the experts that were
there at this hearing it was stunning to
hear and and look at the data about the
mainstreaming of these views he he
really called it just like this
resurgence of the klan in the 1920s
which then it was a lot of catholics
hate and the like and how we're at a
perilous moment for our democracy
where you're seeing larger and larger
portions
view on us versus them within this
country and not just us where we're all
one people with one destiny and so i
would be i would be
i don't want to candy coat the truth of
our country right now
there is a rise in hate there is a rise
in resentment there is a culture of
contempt there are these devices that
are in our lives now that have
algorithms
that are profiting off of making us
more emotional and more involved i tell
the story even about i'm pointing to my
tv
where
you know a friend of mine had a show on
cnn his name is van jones called
crossfire
and i love what brene brown says she
says it's hard to hate up close so pull
people in
and
they decided when it hurt him and newt
gingrich realized they they were
approximate to each other and had lots
in common they wanted to do the last
segment as ceasefire and then after a
few episodes of that the producers
stopped them because they said ratings
were going down
so we have got people who are who are
realizing the incentive their corporate
incentive their political incentive as i
said in the hearing if i yelled at
donald trump during the state of the
union address if i heckled him and
screamed you lie you liar
i may have had a really great
fundraising quarter the next quarter
i know that because when somebody yelled
that to barack obama they had an
incredible great fundraising quarter
and so we're building this powder keg
right now
where we've literally seen people
whipped up to storm the capital of the
united states and remember they had
symbols of anti-semitism and racism
there where peoples
are being preyed upon their
vulnerabilities their hurt their trauma
their fears are being preyed upon
uh by leaders
and that that's my biggest worry for my
country right now for our country i i
really worry
that if we can't figure this out if our
tribalism becomes deeper and it's no
longer an objective analysis hey this
person believes in these values these um
ideas and this ideas but it's more a
tribalism we demonize each other we we
we so uh hate each other that we can't
even talk to each other um
i worry about the future of our country
we have got to figure out a way and is
this tied to the violence that we are
seeing absolutely it is
and and so i
just will finish this point by saying to
you that i'm not despondent because i
believe in the
radical redemptive power of love and
i've seen the data the scientific data
that love goes viral too in fact if
you're it's a stanford researchers
uh to richard our alma mater uh that
have shown that just witnessing a kind
act changes your biochemistry and makes
you more likely to make change and you
can follow it two or three degrees of
separation but we are going to need a
lot more committed
americans to despite your
whipped up differences with somebody
that you can still find
ways to create
connection and see common dignity and
see common destiny and when you ask me
about how things get done down here how
they really get done one of the best
examples of getting through the crap and
the
obstacles it shows
is a story of my implicating myself and
my own bias we all have implicit biases
and there's a guy who's retiring named
inhofe an oklahoma
oklahoma
[Music]
senator who you know we vilify on our
side sometimes he carried a snowball
down to the senate floor to show that
there was no climate change but when i
got down here my mentor guy named bill
bradley told me
go to dinner with your colleagues find
ways to have one-on-ones with them and i
went to bible study in inhofe's office
and i'll never forget walking in and i
saw
on his
shelf
a picture of him and this challenged my
implicit bias because i never thought
i'd see this kind of picture i saw a
picture of him in a little black girl
and i i said sir who who's that and he
says it's my daughter and he tells me
this powerful story about him adopting
her at a tough circumstances fast
forward
months later many months later there's a
big education bill going through and i
want to get an amendment on this bill
about homeless and foster kids and i'm
told there's no amendments being allowed
lamar alexander was blocking the bill
but i remember this point of human
connection and i went to uh inhofe
summoning the spirit of his daughter and
the connection i felt with his humanity
um that we often don't see when we're on
different sides of the political aisle
and i'll never forget he told me i will
co-sponsor your amendment on a bill that
no amendments were being allowed i had
this powerful chairman then i got chuck
grassley then we got other republicans
and it's now the law of the land and
that's just one small story but i think
we need millions of those stories in all
of our lives to begin to start to heal
the fabric and break through the bias
and the venom and the and all those who
profit off of our hate or our contempt
for each other very powerfully put uh
and and and beautifully stated i mean
thank you for that i mean certainly
love connection these are the antidotes
to the rift that is increasingly
dividing us and the misalignment of
incentives whether technological or
economic that are driving this i mean
we're
close enough in age senator that we
remember a time when
a crisis befell our country it brought
us together it didn't drive us apart
into our silos and make us argue with
each other and it really is an
existential crisis and if we can't see
our way forward from that
none of the other issues are ever going
to get addressed so i appreciate you
pointing that out and i know your time
is
running out with us uh but um
it was amazing to have a few minutes to
talk to you and i appreciate you sharing
with us and our audience and and i
really do hope that
at some point in the not too distant
future i can sit down with you in person
and and do a full-blown podcast hey rich
can i make one more uh sure perhaps
emotional plea to your audiences i
love your pod podcast i love listening
to the two you
uh go edit uh uh during uh during the uh
the new kind of evolution of your
podcast where you have this youtube
interstitially
and i just trust and believe that not
only is your podcast strong but it
appeals to people across
the political spectrum and and from all
different backgrounds and
the appeal i want to make to you is that
um
i i was i um i i was doing a new york
times
editorial and and they asked me they
were doing fun questions at the end they
were asking interviewing all the
democratic presidential candidates and
they would ask me funny questions and
they asked me a question what was the
biggest mistake you've ever made and i
thought they think they thought they
were going to get a light answer and i
said look the biggest mistake i made
was when i was living in these high-rise
projects in the lobby of the building i
lived there for eight years this place
called brick towers
and i watched these little amazing boys
grow up all black boys the the leader of
the crew was my dad incarnate and they
were so similar uh they were both whip
smart charismatic born leaders both born
at or below the poverty line both
weren't raised by their mothers raised
by their grandmothers there's just so
many serious similarities eerie to me
one day i came home smelling something i
hadn't smelled since the days of the
enchanted broccoli forest uh
rich uh i smelled it often at stanford
but i smelled it in my lobby which was
pot
and you know stanford students have a
lot more wider margins to experiment
with drugs than black kids in inner city
communities and i immediately thought to
myself i gotta lean in more and i took
them to the movies and i took them
uh you know out to diners i asked them
what their dreams were and they were
really humble dreams
um i still remember uh when one of them
told me they wanted to
learn how to repair cars and maybe one
day have a shop and i boom i thought
okay i'm gonna fix you guys up with
mentors that can help you with all of
your dreams and made commitments to them
that i didn't immediately follow through
on because i was too busy i was running
for to become mayor of the city of
newark and even though i was busy and
didn't follow through
they would still greet me in the lobby
on the end of long campaigning days and
cheer me on lift me up
and then i get elected
and i have death threats against me so
they surround me
with police officers stationed cops in
my in the lobby of the building and the
project safest projects i think i've
been in a long time but the kids i don't
care who you are high school kids don't
want to hang out where the police are so
i just didn't see these young people but
in the back of my mind i'm like i'm on a
mission to help all the children of the
city i'm not i know i'll reconnect with
them soon and then a month into my time
in office i'm called to uh court street
in newark and i get there after a
shooting and there's a body covered up
and i barely affirm
um
i barely affirmed the the death on the
sidewalk and i'm too busy ministering to
the lead to the living and telling them
what we're going to do to drive crime
down
and um
i get home that night and i'm going
through my blackberry
reading reports
and the
name of the murder
was hassan the young man from my lobby
and i will never
tell you talk about shattered
god literally put
my dad in front of me my dad used to
talk about the conspiracy of love all
the small acts of kindness that helped
him get from a rural poor boy black boy
in the 1930s and 40s to become an ibm
executive all the acts of kindness
people going out of their way and here i
had a chance to pay it forward and i'll
never forget going to his funeral which
was like in the bottom of the perry's
funeral home in newark
and it was like descending into the hull
of a ship we were all tied together
in grief wailing and moaning chained to
this horrific daily occurrence in
america which is another young boy in a
box
and
and it haunts me to this day and i
regret it to this day that i didn't do
more
and so i i don't know what it will take
for all of us
to understand that we are so connected
that what you do matters
no matter how busy you are there's
something more you can do
to end this death the pain the hurt the
devastation that happens when a young
man commits suicide
or or or a a woman gets killed by her
boyfriend
or a a a a gun
a legal weapon because it was not a
background check gets into the streets
of communities like mine and is used for
a horrific murder and so my appeal to
the folks here is that democracy is not
a spectator sport it really isn't you
get the government you deserve
and people before us
sacrifice sweat blood we're willing to
die to try to bend the arc of of this
nation's moral
truth and and if there's not if there's
ever a time
uh to to lean in more to change
something that's not partisan it's it's
right now because you and i
i worry even though i think we're going
to pass some legislation i worry that
that you may call me up and say hey can
we have another 15 minutes to have a
conversation about why do we have
another mass shooting and this time god
forbid
if you're a listener here
god forbid it's your neighborhood your
school your mosque your supermarket your
neighborhood and you're wondering why i
didn't do more to stop that pain and
that horror from visiting upon your life
wow
that's
amazing uh amazing words senator thank
you so much for telling us that and
sharing that it's it's like it must
weigh heavy
every day these kinds of things that
you've witnessed and then also hear
about
you must get every day and another
tragic story like that kind of
how do you
how do you deal with that on a daily
basis like the the the responsibility
you carry and and the weight of all of
that look i i am who i am because a
community that i'm not from
uh
embraced me a young law student from
yale who thought i was uh
some kind of savior
and uh knocked me on my ass uh people
like
frank hutchins and uh miss virginia
jones miss yancy you know
um
miss miss miss wright i can tell you the
women who taught me i say i got my ba
from stanford by my phd on the streets
of newark and
i have too many stories about gun
violence but
i i uh
you know
on the worst moment for me
because it was just so traumatizing
we hear these stories about the
shootings where we're not seeing the
bodies while i was on a scene of a
shooting where a teenager got shot
multiple times and i was the
[Music]
person trying to stop them from bleeding
to death
and it was the most gruesome thing i had
ever experienced his foamy blood was
coming from his mouth blood pouring from
his chest and i just i i just was doing
i think about it now i no training so
i'm sticking my hand in his mouth
thinking if i just can clear away the
passage for him to breathe because he's
choking on his blood and
i remember that night trying to scrub
this boy's blood off my hands and i
remember i have never felt more anger at
my country than i did then and i never
felt more of a more of a
of wanting to quit and just be done with
this why was i even trying the problems
seemed so much bigger than me and
i came down into that lobby where the
boys hang out the next morning and
walk through the lobby it was early in
the morning so nobody was there and i
walk into the courtyard
and you know this is why i believe in a
larger power because i was drowning i
was done it was over and then i see the
tenant president this elderly woman this
virginia jones
who
had her son murdered in the lobby in
which i i lived uh uh years before i
moved in a woman had every reason to
move out of those projects in fact i
know the money she made i know where she
works she didn't have to live in this
dangerous neighborhood especially after
her son was killed
and i remember walking out and being
frozen because i saw her back to me
and then she turns around almost like
she could hear my hurt
and then she sees me
and she
does the only thing that i needed at
that moment not to say a word she just
opened her arms and i ran across that
courtyard like a little boy running to
his mom and i'm much bigger than she is
but i felt like i disappeared in her
arms and she held me and this is the
gift she gave me as i started sobbing
she just said two words over and over
that were
hold on to now when i hurt and when i
get angry and when i don't understand my
country
and where i want to give up
and i think about women like that who
never give up i think about
kids from parkland who turn their pain
into purpose i think of mom's demand
action people have lost and turned their
hurt
uh into action and this woman just rubs
my back and she says two words that i
held on to during my times mayor and in
my toughest days here and she just says
to me she's rubbing my back she says
stay faithful stay faithful stay
faithful
and so
i believe that what real hope is about
it's like miss jones it's like hope is
the act of conviction that despair will
never have the last word that no matter
how much it visits upon you
you still have agency you still have
power even if it's just the defiance of
keeping going and not giving up and so
yeah i see shrines on my streets teddy
bears and candles too many damn times
and it's unfortunately black children or
latino children who don't seem to count
as much sometimes to the media
uh don't they don't seem to get the same
coverage and i get angry about systems
uh that date back to
you know when we had overt redlining
they've created a lot of the pain and
hurt but i will tell you this we've come
this far by faith and i have no right to
give up especially when others didn't
and the real challenge i see again
is how do we make other people care
i don't i don't need to change one
person's mind who might believe
that we shouldn't pass universal
background checks or gun licensing or i
don't have to change one person's mind
all we have to do is get the people who
share our beliefs which is the majority
of us to do a lot more to show their
faith because it's my religious
tradition says
and it's a terrible foreboding thing to
say but it says faith without works is
dead
very true um
wow i'm just trying to process
everything that you just shared it's
such a powerful story and i think if you
can carry that resonance of of hope and
channel that into action
um it's inspiring for the rest of us who
might feel paralyzed or powerless or as
if you know our actions don't really
matter because they do and in this
democratic republic that we're
privileged to live in it's incumbent
upon all of us to shoulder that
responsibility and and do what we can
uh to put in motion uh the better world
that we want for ourselves and and
future generations and a lot of you know
you have a lot of athletes that listen
to this
and it's very obvious like nothing
worthwhile is easy nothing that i
watched you do you don't just get up in
the morning and win a national
championship or win a heavyweight boxing
match it is hard it takes endurance and
resilience and pushing through pain and
pushing through a setback but that's
what it takes to be great and i do
believe in the greatness of this country
i think
american history is a perpetual
testimony to the achievement of the
impossible but we who are the inheritors
of this impossible dream that is america
have got to as i fail to do in that one
instance with my dad we've got to
prove worthy of it by by paying it
forward through our sacrifice and our
struggle you you mentioned um
just if i could trouble you with just
one last recommendation because you've
been so generous with your time but
it's uh
you you mentioned that you're you're
you're asking us to give more and do
more
and i see like a lot of the the volume
on the political discussion has gone up
the frequency that the average person is
talking about politics has gone way up
and a lot of that you pointedly pointed
out is related to our phones and
obviously that addiction um
but
often what we're doing is just shouting
into the void there's not really much
getting accomplished other than a bunch
of information
soup which doesn't help us actually it
hurts us what what would you say would
be so you've mentioned some great
organizations what kind of uh if there's
a couple concrete steps that you could
recommend for listeners to kind of get
involved or a first step to getting more
active
yeah i would find others and connect
with others that are
that are doing that i mean this is the
great thing about america now and these
devices i have to say because i don't
want to say there's only negative to
them
is that your fingertips away are connect
the ability to connect with people that
are probably two or three steps ahead of
you sometimes 10 or a mile ahead of you
and understanding what makes a
difference makes a change and so do some
research find these organizations find
these people who are committed to this
kind of change
um and and and never underestimate that
you can do you can make a difference
i've seen i've seen
uh uh
incredibly imaginative young people find
ways to bring pressure to bear amongst
people in power it's really
extraordinary and and and this will be
it because my staff always stands up and
when i
you gotta you gotta go but i am the
physical i am i am the living evidence
that
you doing a little bit of something can
change the world and i always say this
because there was this white guy sitting
on a couch in jersey in 1965
uh watching tv it's just chilling out i
think it was a sunday
and uh
and this was back when we only had three
channels and they
break away the movie most americans were
watching that night was a movie called
judgment at nuremberg
and and suddenly he sees
this these these black these not these
these people on a bridge called the
edmund pettus bridge being viciously
beaten
and he's so disturbed by it he's like i
got to go to alabama and then he laughs
at himself because he just started a
business he can't afford a ticket even
alabama so this guy does what is a great
american tradition he just thinks to
himself okay i'm just gonna do the best
i can with what i have where i am and he
does a calculus in his mind and he
thinks to himself okay i could spare one
hour a week of pro bono work and he does
what i just advised you to do
calls around back then he didn't have an
internet calls around to figure out who
might need a one hour pro bono civil
rights legal work and he finds this
young woman she's now 93 years old but
this young and she's still ahead of the
same organization finds this one who's
head of the fair housing council in
northern new jersey and she's like
hallelujah jesus i need help because we
don't know how to stop
they won't let black people live in
these neighborhoods they keep showing up
and they get steered away and he goes
well let's figure something out and they
design the sting operation where they
get volunteer white couples to volunteer
to follow black couples around
and so what happens is
he goes four years later i get this case
file of this
uh black family moving up from the south
trying getting turned away from house
after house he goes we set up the sting
they fall in love with this house
they're told it's already sold they
leave the white couple comes the house
is for sale they put a bid on the house
on papers are drawn up on the day of the
closing the white couple doesn't show up
the lawyer does and and the black guy
and they confront the real estate agent
real estate agent doesn't give up he
gets up and punches the lawyer in the
face saves the doberman pincher on the
black guy all this kind of rigmarole and
next thing you know that black family
moves into this affluent uh all-white
town as the father would say that we are
the four raisins in the tub of sweet
vanilla ice cream that family is my
family
that's my store
that's how i got to where i grew up and
by 18 years old i was a two position
high school all-american uh on my way to
stanford university on a full
scholarship and i would not be in this
senate office right now
if it wasn't for some white guy years
before i was born deciding to give one
hour a week of pro bono work so don't
tell me
that that your actions right now if
you're listening to this
can't make a difference what you do if
it's righteous and for a cause of
justice and peace and security or the
highest of human virtues love
it resonates it reverberates it it goes
out across space and time and makes a
difference you may not live to see it or
even have the gift of knowing it but but
it makes a difference and now more than
ever we need that kind of radical
love and consistency to say i'm going to
give a little bit
every day or every week or whatever you
can do
for the cause of my country
fantastic
wow i'm inspired adam what are we gonna
do we gotta do more than we're doing i
gotta i gotta do at least one hour a
week i mean this is this is crazy
that's an unbelievable story thank you
so much you guys thank you so much yeah
thank you thank you senator booker
really appreciate it uh have a great
evening and and and look forward to
crossing paths against i hope to see you
in l.a yeah yeah for sure i'm holding
you to it
i'm trust me man we got a lot of talks
we need to talk about america's broken
food system and how washington dc has
created a system where 98
where only two percent of our ag
subsidies go to the thing we tell people
to eat the most of so i'm looking
forward to that 100
and my staff is all here
thanks for letting the senator run long
i thought he was getting 15 minutes we
got 45 40 almost 50 minutes so you've
been very generous thank you everybody
thank you all right
thank you guys
[Music]
you